πρώτη πάλι στο δημοσί αλλά είναι αυτό που μας διαπου μας διαφοροποί από κάποιος άλλους
οργανισμούς και μπορούμε να ελπίζουμε για το μέλλον έσι με λίγι περισσότερη εσιοδοξί ίσως αυτόν
το μοντέλο τη τη πρέπει να το ακολουθήσουν και άλλη οργανισμί αποψημου ώστε είναι αυτόν
που λέγαμεαν υπάρχουν τα κίνητρα να δουλέψουν είνι υπαλλίλι αυτό θα περάσει και στον κόσμο
άρα ίσως γίνει καλύτεροι και κάθυμεενόητα του πολίτη μέσα από αυτά τα κίνητρα που δίνεται
εσείς αχόμι στους υπαλήλουσας θεωρώ ότι σίγουρα είναι μονόδρομος το πράμα είναι δύσκολο όμως είναι
δύσκολο διότι ξανλέω εμείς αναγκαστήκαμε να το κάμουμε διότι είχαμε των ανταγωνισμόνα κάποιο οργανισμεί που
σύντομα παίνουν σε ανταγωνισμό όπως εναι αύκπαραδιγματο χαρί νομίζω θα ακολουθα αρχίσε τα διαμονομάτια θα
κορίσο το διοδρό τοτό δημόσιον το κυρίος δημόσιών που δεν το βλέπω να μπαίνεις ανταγωρισμό
θα έχει μια αεξτρα δυσκολίαν να το κάνει αυτ το πργμα χρειάζεται πολ πολιτική βούληση
για να αλλάξει αυτό το πράγμα οόμως θεωρώ υπάρχει ένας παράγοντας ο παράγοντας τεχνολογία ο
οποίος έρχεται πλέον μέσα στο δημόσιων και ουσι αστετικά αλλάζει των τρόπον που όλον το
δημόσιο θα λιτουργή ι λαή η ψηφιοποίηση όλον το διαδικασιώ και τπλέον ότι όλα θα
τα κάνουμε από δω και όχι να πρέπει να πάμε σε να γραφείων και να
παρακαλέσουμε των λειτουργόν βρίσκεται κνα βάσει το έναφάγελλο να περάσω που δεκαπένται γραφεία για να
ποιανοσφραγί τα σφραγίδα αυτό είναι αυτή είναι η απάντηση απάντηση δηλαδή νομίζω για την για
το για τοκαθααυτό δημοσιών είναι ισαγωγή εχτές τεχνολογίας όταν ισάγουμε τη τεχνολογία θα γίνονται τα
πράγματα χωρίς να μιλάμε με κάποιους ανθρώπους αλλά θα γίνονται μόνον από συσθήμαται όποτε πρέπει
να βοηθήσουμε όλι και εμείσεις προσπαθούμε να το κάνουμε των ηφιπουργόν έρευνας και νοτομίας και
ς